so what do we need to get into here is
what is a wasp
we're going to talk about the history
like who they are do these people just
come out of the blue right now what are
the credentials
you know how i would say raise your hand
but like
who's ever heard of o wasp and to be
fair
i hadn't heard of them until a couple
years ago when the company i was working
for had a security presentation
come in for all the devs and
just opened up this whole world to me um
so it's okay if you've never heard of a
wasp we won't hold that against you
um and one of the things i'm going to
focus in on
is the owasp top 10.
this isn't necessarily like a late night
show top 10 but this is these are the
top 10 crucial things
that developers and just companies in
general should know if you're running a
website that's
um even a brochure website is exposable
to
hacking but if you you know especially
if you run an e-commerce store if you're
doing
anything that is touching a database
basically
on the internet um you need to know
about all these threats
so i'm gonna focus in on an example
which is the um xml external entities
which i just think is cool everyone's
heard of you know some of these like
injections
and uh across you know xss
um but i'm gonna touch on this one real
quick then we're going to talk about
prevention
of some of these top tens and then the
mentality of
as a developer how can we be proactive
versus reactive
nobody wants that call at two in the
morning that their database has been you
know compromised
so how can you be proactive and at least
reduce that
to a small amount percentage of you know
a possibility
and then we're gonna get into some fun
stuff um this would be a live demo
um because of course we all like that
high excitement for live things failing
but
i have screenshots today but we're gonna
get into like the mind of an attacker
how as a developer
sometimes we get our blinders on i say
sometimes every time we get blinders on
and
code works perfectly it works exactly
how we intended it
great that's not what they are looking
at this like all right where'd they mess
up what can we do how can i fuzz this
so there are a couple tools that owasp
gives you
that can get you into that mentality and
thinking to where
and it might not necessarily be even
your code that you're checking but your
team's code or co-worker somebody's code
um and you can start thinking like them
instead of looking at your code like
does it work or does it not work
and going and fixing it real quick all
right
so the history of osp owasp is the open
web application security
project um it launched in 2001
and it became a non-profit profit in
2004 so they have
you know over 20 years or 20 years of
history
and what i want you to look at here is
kind of where
their foundations are in their mentality
so their principles they as they state
are you know they're open
everything at lost is radically
transparent from our finances to our
code
they're global anyone around the world
anywhere
can join and participate in the
community
um there's no no certifications no
licenses no fees
none of that stuff um innovative which
is just kind of the hacker mentality
they encourage and support innovation
experiments and solutions for software
security challenges
that sounds good that sounds like a
great thing to be a part of
and integrity of course respectful
supportive
truthful and vendor neutral so
with all of that being said even though
you might never have heard of them
given these principles here how could
you
not to bash anybody but let's say like a
norton or
mcafee do they have these principles
you know what are they they're they're a
company a for-profit company
um nothing against that not bashing
capitalism but
i would prefer to look at something like
this
just because they don't really have
anything to gain from this
they're a non-profit they're out here
doing doing the good for the people
doing the good for us to make
our lives easier as developers
okay so if you were to venture to the
owasp
page they have a lot of a lot of
information there
um a lot of just good practical use
cases
for security and securing your your
application
now they're not necessarily a place that
you would go
if you're looking for the latest cve if
you're looking up
and trying to search different exploits
that are already available
this is more of a community page to
encourage
and support the security
community so one of their projects that
they have
and they're most famous for is the oauth
top 10 like i was
like i said earlier so let's look at
this
the top 10 is a standard awareness
document for developers web application
security
it represents a broad consensus about
the most critical security risks
to debt web applications
so they look at everything they're
vendor neutral like they stated
their their um
code language agnostic they don't care
what you coded in
they're looking at all around security
for web applications
and they're not necessarily looking at
just big companies like
when target went down you know they were
aware of those security flaws before all
of that
they don't just focus on the big fortune
500 companies they care about the mom
woocommerce store that's set up as much
as
target
so what the top 10 will get you are some
ideologies and
concepts that again start to bring this
security
mentality into your toolbox that when
you're developing
and you're figuring out your algorithm
or you know what you need to do
these things start popping up in your
head like oh where are these variables
coming from
what systems am i touching with this is
this is this query the best that it
could be
how am i protecting this query
um and again platform agnostic i don't
care if it's java
c sharp php delphi
whatever if you're on linux if you're on
microsoft
no matter most of these are the bigger
concept
hacks not down to the specifics you can
go and google
how to find a specific hack anywhere but
if you want to be able to
control the methodology and protect your
system from a you know 30 000 foot
level here's where you go
so i put this in here because i've used
this before
um if you're trying to again
explain timelines for projects what you
need what you don't need
if you're trying to prove your case
to your manager or to somebody else
in within your company this what
these hacks do are multi-departmental
they will affect your sales they will
affect your
um your business in general every
department your marketing
if they put out something that has a
hack in it or that has a vulnerability
in it
they're going to be affected you're
affected because you have to fix it and
then
your company's affected because you've
just lost sales or you've lost you know
you've lost customers because you got
hacked so this does affect everybody in
your company so you can bring this to
the table
when you're trying to fight for
something
and again personally i believe this is a
reputable source
been around for 20 years you know in the
it world
that's a pretty good life span
all right so let's get into one of the
top 10 here
injection we've all we've all kind of
heard of injections
um and this is where you know typically
it's sql
but injection flaws such as sql sql os
and ldap injection
occur when untrusted data is sent to an
interpreter
as part of a command or query so
interpreter
any one of your languages that you're
using and
what the concept here is that while we
develop our own code
we know what we're sending in and out
and pathing passing through
but when somebody injects something in
there who knows what can happen
they can throw in some you know
malicious code and all of a sudden they
get all your passwords from the database
no good
so almost any source of data can be an
injection vector
environment variables parameters
external internal web services
and all types of users even even the
users the user's name
if you've never heard of little bobby
tables go once we're done here during
lunch go google
little bobby tables
so injection flaws occur when an
attacker can send hostile data to an
interpreter
i wish that they would go in there and
you know send some kind of injection
that would give everybody
amazing credit scores it's typically not
what they do
so we're going to call it thank you
dylan yeah little bobby tables
typically hostile malicious is the
intent of
the injections so
injection flaws are very prevalent
particularly in legacy code
so we all know this even it's 2020 right
now
awesome by the time we get to 2025 we'll
look at our 2020 code and go
oh why are we writing stuff like that so
think about your
legacy code that we all know that is
sitting back there we have those
legacy functions we have legacy um
classes that are sitting out there that
we just we know we should fix we know we
need to fix but well they work and we
don't
have time so there's one big
use case to go to your manager and say
we need to spend time on this
excuse me um injection vulnerabilities
are often found in sql ldap or xpath
uh any database query os commands
xml parsers basically anything
that takes any kind of input from the
web whatsoever any form
that has posts or get or put or patch
or delete anything that you can send
a data packet to is vulnerable
and the way that people find these are
impressive programs
scanners and fuzzers we used to call
them script kitties back in the day
but now it's a profession and you can
sit there with a with nmap
with um metasploit and scan
and you can just scan a website and
it'll come back and tell you exactly
what's open what's not open what
services are running
where there's a potential for
vulnerability so
you don't even have to sit there all
night with your you know mountain dew
and red bull
and hit websites you can just run a
script go to bed
wake up the next morning and you'll have
a list of all the things that
you need it's kind of like war dialing
back in the day
so here's a standard injection example
so example.com app account view id
equals
and we got a tick or
one equals one so the injection is the
or
one equals one and what that does to a
query
is no matter what is in the id
equals if it's you know username
password if it's
getting some kind of um you know product
data
this one's account view so we're gonna
get account data from a customer
probably
if anything is invalid like if your
password is invalid
typically what that would do is return
oh password invalid we're gonna you know
not authenticate you
you're done but if you inject an or one
equals one well what is one equals one
it's true so if all of this big query
or or true then return this
so data kind of a simple thing there um
yeah that's a fun one that's been around
forever
but that's as simple as it has to be you
know
not trying to scare people if you know
they've never heard of these things but
this isn't a mastermind like cia
basement full of people
this is very simple stuff and if you
protect against it you don't have to be
afraid of it
so yeah i just explained that and of
course more dangerous attacks could
modify
or delete data or even invoke stored
procedures you could do a lot of damage
with you know really really specific
queries
um so the to go
back to that real quick one of the os or
wasp
top tens are injections so they're just
they're
classifying that out there another one
here is insufficient logging
and monitoring um
i'm an advocate for logging i mean most
most services do if you run apache or
nginx there's always an apache or nginx
log
php there's a php log mysql same
thing when you hit an error
or when something is going on most
people turn to the code
if you know php isn't working and the
page comes up
it just comes up wrong you don't know
where to go typically they go straight
to the code
and look at that code again and try to
figure out what was wrong with it
i always go to the log files tail a log
file
hit the error again and it'll tell you
exactly which
file is there what is missing and what
the error is same thing with apache or
nginx it'll tell you exactly what
happened
now knowing that after the fact
is okay and that's cool but
these logs can also be monitored real
time
and there are systems in place to do
that
um exploitation of insufficient logging
and monitoring is the bedrock of nearly
every major incident
attackers rely on the lack of monitoring
and timely response they
know that you are not checking your logs
they know that you
might not even know where they are in
your server that's the it's guys problem
i just write my java code i don't care
um so they they attackers rely on this
to achieve their goals without being
detected
if i'm going to attack your site i'm
going to attack it for
a week to like sniff around and see
what's going on
i might do it at two o'clock in the
morning i might only do it for half an
hour and i might
set a time to where or um
set a variable to where i do it every 10
minutes
so that i'm not hitting your site in a
big chunk of
i'm not hitting your site all at once
and you're seeing me um
you're seeing all these errors come out
but if you're not looking at your
log files you're not going to see that
anyways
when i was working at a um unnamed
company
here in wisconsin we would our website
would be slow
we'd get different things um nginx would
quit on us and i started tailing the
logs
and i would put in some some little um
variables here in my tail so that things
would come up in different colors
i would group ip addresses and we found
out that we were getting slammed by
a chinese ip address now this company
specifically only sold to
the united states we didn't sell
internationally at all
so there's no reason for an ip address
in china to be hitting us
a and that many times in a row well
this was after two days of this incident
happening and nobody
not even the i.t guys looking at it
nobody was looking at the logs
this could have gone on for months and
months and months they could have
collected a ton of data
and well that's bad
so get in the habit of tailing your logs
knowing where they are and seeing what's
normal when a log is scrolling by
it's kind of like the matrix but if you
look at it for a little while
you'll be able to see the patterns that
are normal you'll be able to see when an
ip hits you 10 times in a row and you
get an error
versus what normal traffic looks like so
that's one of the ways to get around
that
one strategy um it's examine logs
following a pen test
now that's so that's already a saying
that we're gonna have a pen test on our
site
let's let's do this of course look at
the log files afterwards
and you'll know when they were attacking
you when they were sniffing you
and you can keep that in mind for later
when you see those patterns again
so yeah like i was saying most
successful attacks start with the
vulnerability probing
that's where they're just looking out
every five minutes at two o'clock in the
morning
just to check um here we go fun fact in
2016
identifying a breach took an average of
191
days um so
that's a long time and that's when you
get those
reports on the news of equifax or
something being hacked
well man well that does that happen
today
no that happened last summer you know
and you're like why did it take a year
for this to get out now
that my credit card was stolen a year
ago
uh or my my social security number was
stolen a year ago
well this is why they didn't even know
all right so another one on the uh
top ten and if you're in the wordpress
community at all
you already know about this but using
components with known vulnerabilities
now this makes sense if let's say
this is common knowledge if you're
buying a house would you buy a door
that has a big hole in it no but you can
see the hole
you know it's easy everybody can reach
their hand in and open up the door with
the hole if you're installing a plug-in
that's a gallery plug-in
for your wordpress site and it works it
looks great and
you see that a hundred thousand other
people have downloaded it
it works it's great well what if there's
a major security flaw on that
now you've just welcomed a hole into
your website
and you know you literally click the
thumbs up button
and you installed it so
you know how do you how do you get
around that it's kind of tough but in
the wordpress community
one of the main mantras is keep
everything up to date
good thing is that plugin developers are
constantly putting out plugins almost
annoyingly
to where every day you have to keep
updating and updating and updating but
what that's doing is keeping you on top
of everything you can go to your
customers and clients and say
we're all up to date we're good you can
run some other scans too but
the main point is don't install things
or do a little research before you
install
or use components within your framework
or your your applications
um don't use them if they have known
vulnerabilities
sometimes you can't help it sometimes
it's sudo
within linux that has a vulnerability
that just happened a little while ago
what can you do about that well nothing
that is kind of after the fact
once they put out a new release update
it quickly but
you have to keep aware of these things
you can't just go into work clock in
code and then clock out read those other
websites
read hacker news you know stay on reddit
figure out what's going on in your world
to know what are the most vulnerable
components out there and if you're using
them or not
so prevalence of this issue is very
widespread
component heavy development patterns can
lead to development teams
not even understanding which components
they use
have you ever had to purge an
application because
you are using a million jquery plugins
you have a calendar you have form
validation uh you have
auto scrolling under page because you
hate people um
you have uh several things that compress
your images when they're uploaded
you're using so many components that
when you get a new developer on your
team
you have to spend an entire two-hour
meeting just to tell them what you're
using
now it's kind of the world we live in
now
but you can still you are still the
owner of this project
and this application and if you have the
oauth top 10 and this knowledge behind
you
you can make a case for consolidating
for rolling your own not just trusting
blindly what's out there
on the interwebs
so yeah and some scanners help in
detection
there are some things that can help you
figure out if you are vulnerable or not
um but really determining this this the
exploitability requires additional
effort so like i said it's kind of the
world we live in
and we do have to be a little bit
proactive on this
this is not just a one and done install
it and it works great
move along this is keeping up to date
with these things
a little responsibility as developers
so yeah just reiteration here some while
some known vulnerabilities lead to only
minor impacts
some of the largest breaches to date
have relied on exploiting known
vulnerabilities and components
so and just depending on what they're
protecting or what you have on your
website
that's what's exposed that's what you
can lose
all right so cross-site scripting um
this is kind of like injection um this
can lead to an injection
attack but automated tools
this is very easy automated tools can
detect and exploit
all of the forms of xss and they're also
freely available
exploitation frameworks i mentioned
metasploit earlier
metasploit is fantastic for the um
infosec community they install it you
run
different different modules and they
attack a site and
return back all these beautiful reports
saying yes this is
open this is vulnerable go here and
attack so
a lot less time is spent on their end
trying to figure out
how to attack but that also means that
these are available to everybody
but that also means they're available to
everybody as a developer
why aren't you running medes floyd
against your application
to figure out where it's vulnerable a
lot of times
i know personally i've been there where
it's
in my head it's like well i'm just
creating more work for myself
well yes you are creating more work for
yourself but you're
ensuring that your application is secure
uh second most prevalent issue on the os
os
the wasp top 10 is found in around
two-thirds of all applications
and yeah it's a agnostic to what code
you're developing on
all of the frameworks all of the code
are vulnerable
um and like most of the other ones
the impact is severe too not really but
either way
they're getting especially with the
cross cross-site scripting
where they um focus in on are on the
browser itself so all your cookies all
your history
when chrome tells you do you want me to
save that password do you want me to
save that credit card
those are all saved in sessions and
values and variables and those are all
vulnerable
to cross-site scripting so it's
important information that is
available out there um another one
security misconfiguration so that's kind
of generic
and out there but it makes sense as well
if your security is misconfigured then
well that's a pretty good attack vector
for someone to go in on
um attackers will often attempt exploit
unpatched flaws
or access default accounts unused pages
unprotected files of directories etc to
gain unauthorized access or knowledge of
the system
if i go to pants.com and i want to
i want to attack it what can i do i can
go to slash
wp-admin that'll tell me if it's a
wordpress site and i can go on that
knowledge from there i can just go to
slash
admin and i'll know there'll be a form
there maybe and i'll know what i need to
start attacking with do the
username and password what is that file
connected to is it connected to any
javascript basically
having having those things open and
easily accessible
and guessable on the web is just an open
door for people to at least get their
foot
in you might not have direct access to
your website the back end
but it's a good starting point
um security misconfiguration can happen
at any level of an application stack
including the network services platform
web server application server database
frameworks custom code and
pre-installed virtual machines
containers
or storage um automated scanners are
useful in detecting this configurations
use of default accounts or
configurations unnecessary services
legacy options
etc they don't even continue to list
them because it's literally
everything you can have the best
most secure through https through a vpn
website that requires you know oauth and
all that to log in
but if you have an open telnet port on
the server
or if your ftp account is
anonymous with no password
i don't care about any of that front-end
connection i can get into your back end
now
and that's just a big security
misconfiguration
so like they said it's on all parts of
the stack
you can only do so much depending on
your company
you just have control over your
application and the programming of it
that's great do your part there
if you have more i know i've worn
several hats before
from network all the way up to you know
front-end css
do what you can but be aware that
at any point no matter how secure you
think things are
there's always a possibility of
another part just being wide open that
no one's even looking at
and that's exactly what hackers are kind
of betting on
all right broken access control it's
pretty much the same
all of these like i hope you're picking
up on kind of a pattern
here the security mindset needs to be
a holistic view of everything in your
stack
system code to
user level access so
you know access control is detectable
using many means
scanners like we were talking about an
absence of access controls
in certain frameworks lead obviously to
exploits
so access control weaknesses are common
due to the lack of automated detection
and lack of effort uh effective
functional testing by application
developers
uh big fancy words for you know you
might you might not
you do a qa on your application but are
you really trying to hack it
are you really putting in um letters
when it asks for your telephone number
or your social security number are you
putting in
numbers when asked for letters are you
putting in white spaces or ascii
characters
uh utf-8 code things that could break
your
your code i've said it before but we get
our blinders on to where after a week of
working on a project we just want that
project to be done
we're not looking to make more work for
ourselves but what that does
is opens up all of these
attack vectors to hackers
and again the impact is as severe as
the connection point as severe as what
you have behind there
do you have credit card numbers behind
there or do you have to go orders that
you know tell me that that i like to
order
you know grilled cheese sandwiches you
know
to each person it means different things
but
any amount of data that's leaked is
important and should not happen
broken authentication i feel honestly
like a broken record at this point
so attackers have access to hundreds of
millions of valid usernames and
passwords
this is actually something different i
apologize for that
this is this is really good so
as we kind of all know there's those um
we've seen the commercials for like
lifelock and things like that that offer
the
dark web scanning and that's a great
promotional tool and i love
i love hearing all of that
um but what it really means are when
something does hack and or something
does happen and a hacker gets in through
an injection
and they get a dump at your database and
then they go and put on paste bin
or a dark web version of paste bin
uh lifelock is now scanning all of those
looking for you know gunner to
ingebreath and seeing if my account's
there and then alerting me and saying
hey your stuff's on
the internet at this point in my life
everything's out there on the internet i
don't even care um
but it's attackers have access to all of
this we're going to see this in a second
and they have they have all of your old
passwords they have all of your current
passwords
okay that's a little too much they don't
have all of your current passwords or
all of your old passwords
but most likely there's at least one
password out there
that you might have used before that's
sitting in a text file somewhere
and those can be used especially if you
use them across multiple accounts
facebook and then any of your utilities
you know your email and um
google gmail or something
using the same password if it's out here
in one of these files
it's not very good but just the
knowledge that
they have all of the access to this data
should be something and again if they
have access to it so do you
you can go and get this and check your
systems to make sure that
they're not vulnerable
so this just goes into session
management and that
applications should be able to check
sessions and you can't just
i don't think anybody does this anymore
but you can't just have a login
and password that goes all right you're
good like session variables our thing
and um something we should continue to
do
but also it is something that's out
there and we can find websites right now
i'm sure
that just just kind of check against a
unhashed database and we'll let you on
this website
so here's where rocky comes in everybody
raised their hand if you've heard of
rocky
rocky is one of the most well-known
password
text files and it's got a pretty good
history in december of 2009
the company rock you who developed games
and applications for myspace
and then moved over into facebook so
this is
from a while ago the company experienced
the data breach resulting in the
exposure of over 32 million user
accounts
the company used an unencrypted database
that's problem number one
to store account data including plain
text passwords no
no no plain text so as opposed to
password hashes
as well as passwords to connected
accounts
so they have their account for rock you
and then that account is connected to
myspace
and that password is in there as well so
we're talking yeah facebook myspace and
webmail services
rockyou would also email the password
unencrypted to the user during account
recovery
these are all things that we kind of
know in our mind
don't do this now but when this was
prevalent 32 million user accounts
were taken
so they also did not allow using special
characters and their passwords
um the hackers use a 10 year old
sql vulnerability so they have
unencrypted passwords they have linked
unencrypted passwords
and they have a 10 year old known
injection
vulnerability that are all sitting out
there
and they use that to gain access to the
database the company took days to notify
users after the incident and initially
incorrectly reported that the breach had
only affected older applications when it
actually affected
all all right no good
so i'm going to try to get this quickly
here but xml internal
external entities are basically another
attack vector where if you use xml and
lots of legacy systems do lots of
current systems do
i know major things like i think ups
does fedex
those apis still use soap and xml
well there's a part of xml where you can
you can include external entities files
whatever you want and so
the easy thing is that you can turn this
off but it's in the configuration on
the the apis part if
the config is mismanaged if it's
incorrectly
set then the external entities are
allowed
and what this leads to is the
excuse me what this leads to is the fact
that a hacker can go in
and say sure you're calling this utility
well i want you to call this utility
this is one that i have control of and
now i own your api
and i can access several different
things or
yeah we're going to show you an example
here in a second
so external entities is application
vulnerable
the bottom line is yes if if it's xml
it is vulnerable
and what this can do at the bottom here
being vulnerable to xxe attacks likely
means that the application is vulnerable
to a denial of service attack so i might
not just
i might not be able to get like your
passwords or your database credentials
but i can just shut you down
and so the billion last attack is a
denial of service attack that targets
xml parsers this is a very simple
example of a very powerful attack
what it is is an xml bomb or
the exponential entity expansion attack
if you want to sound
if you're trying to use it in a uh you
know presentation or something
so let's look at what that does and how
it blows up your system
so in xml is very easy
what we're doing is we have the xml
header
we have doctype naming it lulls and then
we have an entity that we're creating
called
lol cool next line
okay we're just we're creating an entity
called lull2 and we're referencing
lol 10 times okay so now lull two
has ten lulls in it sweet
okay lull three now has ten little
twos in it and little twos have
ten l uh lulls in it okay
okay i see where we're going here so now
we're all the way down to
lull nine which has lull eights and so
on and so on
and then all we're doing is displaying
we're calling
the entity lull nine
which has a million lulls if you've been
doing the math
in it and this inevitably will kill a
server
you get denial of service attacks you
get the 500 errors
all with these lines of code and all
because your xml
is vulnerable because it's been
misconfigured and mismanaged
there's another one that's kind of
direct to the point
um here's the the external entity
and so we have doctype foo cool entity
xse system file etsy password
so instead of if you look at the third
line it's a
you know stock check product id and it
calls this external entity
but in our case we've modified it to
where we want the etsy password file
so instead of getting the product id we
get all the passwords and i know the
passwords are hashed and all that stuff
but we know account names at that point
we can run um jack the ripper we can run
several different cracking
programs to get those passwords and
get into your system three lines of code
all right so really quickly here got a
few minutes left
let's get into what what we can do with
that proactive versus reactive how is
developers
how can we be proactive in this
so oh wasp there's several of these kind
of things out there but obas
did it first i think and does it great
and it's free so it's called the juice
shop
what it is is an e-commerce store but
it's a whole
training system once you go to it and
you can install it locally if you want
to but you can use it also for free
just on the web it's an e-commerce
system that they want you to hack
and they guide you through it completely
once you log in once you get there
it tells you what it is and says all
right let's go
and so the g shop yeah the first task
within the g
shop is well let's find the scoreboard
how are you gonna know
like how you're progressing if you don't
have a scoreboard
so the first task is let's find it and
they give you a nice pop-up that says
hey let's
let's look in the javascript code in the
dev tools your browser
and tells you how to open it up this is
you know right-click inspect element
that kind of thing um and they even say
or you can just start url guessing so
our goal is to find the scoreboard url
there's no links to it anywhere
it's supposed to be for admins only and
so they say
all right go find it let's look in the
javascript
cool let's look in the javascript so
here are the javascript files that they
are referencing within there
uh they all seem pretty standard you
know runtime polyfills vendor
main cool so
what i did when i when i ran through
this i went through each one some of
them
are you know gulped and compressed and
obfuscated so
you don't really know what's going on so
look for the ones that aren't
um so here's one that's just kind of
compressed
it's not necessarily obfuscated and i
don't know if you can see it or not but
what i did was
once it opened up i'm not going to look
through all that i'm just going to
search so i'm searching for the word
score
and there's several hits that are
highlighted there
but if we take a look at this one right
in the center of the screen
we have return um
dollar sign or hash slash
score dash board so right and it's set
to a window location
we're returning it it looks like
exactly what we're looking for so we
just
go back to the web page type in slash
score
dashboard and bam we're in the
scoreboard and we see we have the first
star
eight of nine filled up that's the first
step and then here are the rest
of what we are asked to do
access a confidential document perform a
dom xss attack
with an iframe read read a privacy
policy
that seems interesting there's some more
xss attacks in there
um you can log in as admin as another
one you can
set comments as a different user
they give you access to be able to do
all of this
and and by doing these you're not
necessarily gaining the skill as a pen
tester or
even as a hacker what you're doing is
it's
hopefully should be triggering things in
your mind of like oh i wrote code that
that does this or protects this i wonder
if that's vulnerable let me go back and
look at it
look at you can start looking at your
application the same way that you're
looking at this
so i really like the g-shop it's super
fun
the examples again broken authentication
broken access control security
misconfiguration
using components with known
vulnerabilities insufficient logging and
monitoring
all of those will come into play
when you use g-shock second and last
thing for
owasp zap zap is one of those scanners
that i was talking about earlier
again it's free on their website
and i think everybody should use it go
use it by the end of the day on your
application to make sure it's secure
so it's the zed attack proxy
and basically lots of buttons lots of
tabs
lots of things here but it's not that
difficult to run
and what this will do is scan your site
for known vulnerabilities
and different attack vectors so on this
next screen here
um it's pretty easy quick start
automated scan
and you put in the url and you can set
some things you know is it ajax
ajax spider firefox headless what kind
of agent are you using
and if it's your own or if it's on a
local host you can do it really quick or
you can
set different timing on it doesn't
really matter
but let's see what some of the results
are so i'm running this
on my own website um i believe this was
gonna yeah gunnar.org
so at the top we're getting we're
getting all of these
this feedback we're getting the source
code and then the bottom pane
are the results of the specific alerts
that we should be looking at
um just going down the list there's you
know
x frame options header not set absence
of anti-csrf tokens
cookie no http only policy crosstalk
domain javascript and source function
file inclusion
couple down looks like there's 416
checks for web browser
xss protection not enabled
this utility is very easy to get your
hands on
very easy to learn and understand and
can save you super super heartache
and a headache if you find something
that you can fix
easily and you know you'll get a pat on
the back at work people think you're
looking out for
for the company and for your application
which you are you don't want
somebody in russia or wherever not
picking on russia
to run this find the vulnerability and
then break into your site
you can check this you almost have no
excuse as a developer you not only
should be proud of your code
but you should be proud of the security
of your website and here you have
access to figure this stuff out
so yeah just another picture look it's
just it's doing all the hard work for
you
and you just get a nice report at the
end
so in conclusion all devs should be
aware of this
tell your friends tell your team
go study up on it i'm not an expert on
this
but i'm telling y'all so we all should
be advocates
i i definitely argue for internal pen
testing
you don't have to be an infosec person
with a degree or a certificate or
whatever you don't have to
necessarily hire a huge team to go and
do stuff
you can run these programs yourself and
learn a lot about your
application uh zap some things i didn't
mention
lin pease lin pease is a linux
privilege escalation program it'll run
against your site
if give it an ip address and it'll tell
you how
it's vulnerable to a privileged
escalation so if you get in as www data
and you get to a command prompt you
might not necessarily be able to do
anything
but if you run lin p's it'll tell you
which systems
are vulnerable for you to go in and then
you root bam again
it's automated it just happens these you
can run
um an nmap nmap is pretty standard um
across the board tells you your open
ports and services
file systems that are running all of
those things it's a
big tool but there's a couple really
easy scans
just to get the basic information on how
vulnerable
your physical or virtual server might be
um use the oauth top 10 is your security
policy just take the bold headlines
go through that list and say how do we
want to treat this how do we want to
secure this how do we want to address
these problems
and create your security policy from
that uh there's nothing wrong with that
and i think that's a great head start
instead of nothing
all right and with that i am done and we
can
i'd say go ahead and start asking
questions um
here's where you can find me again these
slides are up at gunner.org
200 okay twitter gunnard
instagram i'm way more active on uh
gunnard e
or just email me but let me know if you
have any questions
or anything else and yeah with that i am
i'm done